almost seemed like Josie redirected it
instead of
you know drifting that pocket than that
I think he was a little unsure what was
around it with the pass between the legs
and then Markov scores what a move
and the Panthers tied the game at one
[Music]
oh a chance at one end
for Paul Stassney and then barkov goes
to work back the other way
there's the chance and then back at the
other it looks like barkov's going to go
between the legs here Kenny but yeah I
don't think he ever does
oh and he brings it back so he made it
look like he was going to go and make
that move between the legs and then the
patience here Jonesy to wait wait wait
and then have the angle to beat ranta
yeah how good has he been in this series
take a look at the 18t 5G netcam brontod
stretched out as far as he possibly
could go and Markov with a Dandy